هل كان شبكه الطرق وشبكه النقل اللي
موجوده النهارده احنا داخلين في حوالي 17
18 مليون جنيه احنا كان ممكن ما نعملش ده
ونسيبها كده هي القضيه اللي حصلت ايه انا
بكلمكم منتصر صراحه وجوده والله مقصود ان
احنا اضطرينا نعمل كل حاجه احنا بنشتغل في
كل حاجه ما كانش عندنا تعرف ان انا
اقولويات اسيب حاجه واخلي حاجه الوقت ثاني
كنا محتاجين نشتغل في كل الملفات لان كل
الملفات كانت عايزه جهد وعايزه مواجهه
حقيقيه حتى تستطيع الدوله ان تجابه
مستقبلها وتقابل الامان اللي هي بتعملها
طيب انا برده عايز اقول شبك الكاميرا انا
ساعتها انا بلف كثير في لوحدي يعني اقول
يا ترى لو ما كانش ده اتعمل كان فسح تمشي
ازاي ما حدش بيسال نفسه السؤال ده يقول لو
ما كنتش الشبكه دي الطوارئ بالطريقه ديت
كانت الدوله دي هتمشي ازاي مش بس في
القاهره ومش بس في اسكندريه انا باتكلم
على الدوله المصريه في كل حاجه
الخلاصه اللي انا عايز اقولها ان ما كانش
عندنا طرف او سوء تقدير في الموضوع ده طرف
يعني احنا ما كانش مهم وعملناها ولا سوء
تقدير في الموضوع لا بس خلي بالكم انتم
بتعملوا ده حجمه وقدره الدوله المصريه قد
ايه عشان يتعمل ده كله في المده الزمنيه
اللي هم السبعه سنين دول
تحب كبير قوي وضخم جدا وانا عايز اقول لكم
لو النهارده احنا بنحاول نعمله دلوقتي
والسنين اللي جايه يتكلف قد اللي اتعمل ده
ثلاث اربع خمس مرات